Okay.
Um,
I found out about you,
uh,
I guess there was so many,
just I,
I get a lot of interesting stuff tweeted at me and uh,
I read one of your Breitbart pieces and I was like,
check this motherfucker out.
And then I found out that you're gay and you're,
you're a part of this gamer gate,
but you're in the game.
You're on the,
you were on the side of the people that were not the ultra progressive's like,
and then you were in these debates against these radical feminism chicks and
shutting them down.
And I was very kind about me.
You've placed some video,
look at this motherfucker.
You're a unicorn.
Like they don't like people like you.
I'm not supposed to exist into the progressive rules of the universe.
I should not be.
Yeah,
you should.
You're not supposed to be like fairly buttoned down and conservative and,
and fare well also factually correct.
Like all the stuff that you would,
the thing that I'd seen,
you've gotten in his argument about why certain women and gravitate towards
certain jobs and men gravitate towards jobs and this idea that,
that a lot of this is just cultural.
A lot of this is something that we're pushing upon young men and young women.
And you were like,
well this isn't the case at all,
but it's hilarious to watch someone confronted by.
Like they expect that to come from a me.
They expected to come from some looking like I ought to be supporting the exam
and on paper like paper,
I should,
you don't want to,
I'm a metropolitan and the other circumstances I would be a liberal.
I'm a homosexual.
I listen.
I'd like pop culture,
you know,
all of those things.
I shouldn't really exist.
But I do unfortunately for that one 10th of your tweets are about how fabulous
your Harris.
Yeah.
So Black Dick,
you know,
any of those subjects,
his hair or you know,
the men that I'm into,
it's very,
very difficult for them to beat me for one simple reason,
which is they've never been questioned.
I've never been called in any of this stuff by anybody serious or anybody who's,
who doesn't conform to the progressive rules if identity politics.
So when they come from me,
they usual the usual response from a feminist to anybody bringing facts or,
um,
account as a serious counter argument is simply to dismiss them as a sexist or a
bigot or misogynist.
It's really tough to make the allegation against me.
I love women.
All my friends are women.
I don't have any,
I don't have a dog in the fight sexually speaking.
I don't care if,
you know,
I don't,
I don't want to bang them whatever size they are,
however they behave.
So they really don't,
they don't have that over me as very,
very difficult to come up against a guy that you cannot make a convincing
argument,
uh,
of bigotry gains.
So you have to argue on the facts.
And of course the facts are on my side.
Well that's what the deal is.
They can't dismiss you instantaneously because of what you represent because
what you represented,
well look,
we got the dirt on him.
He's,
he's,
he's gay and he's fabulous shit.
What are we going to do?
What are we going to say?
Well this is once you start,
once you start to hit the right off,
you note that you get calls from friends.
You say said this,
this person I emailed me trying to check you out.
This happened to me about a year ago.
So I,
I sort of hit an a journalist for 10 years.
It had some good staff,
broken,
some big stories,
but I never really,
I never really kind of crossed over into entertainment into the mainstream and
just started to happen about year ago and I start to get emails from friends and
they were saying,
so what's going on here?
Like people keep emailing me,
asking me about you like trying to ask like in back in 2011 did he really do
this?
And what I've realized is when they,
when they recognize you as a threat,
when they identify you as somebody could do them damage,
they start going on maneuvers,
trying to find out everything about your,
trying to find out what the worst stuff they have on you is so that he can
dismiss you as a bigot or a sexist or a Neo Nazi or whatever.
They can come up with anything they can grasp out because their strategy is to
dismiss the,
is to dismiss the speaker by attacking the speakers credibility.
Because that way they never have to even consider the merits of the argument.
They haven't been able to do that with me.
Um,
which is why feminists now refuse to bait me,
debate me on TV because they know they'll lose.
Um,
they can't bring out all,
they can't bring out,
they've got this battery of dismissing just dismissal tactics that they've
amassed over the last 30 years and they've got so complacent because they've
never had,
you know,
a Sassy gay person and come up and say it.
You're talking bullshit and you're hurting men and here are the facts.
They've never had it before,
so they've never built up on arsenal to fight it,
you know,
so this is,
this is why I went and why I'll cook.
I'll keep winning because they don't really know how to deal with an argument on
its own merits.
And in any case,
of course the facts are on our side.
Well,
it's also this conversation that we're having right now is about war.
You're saying winning and losing and they're taking tactics and strategies to
look up dirt on the opposition.
They're going,
they're treating.
This is,
it's,
this is an ideological war is not a debate about the facts of the issue.
And I think that's of it because the left has always seen this as a war.
And the gender warriors,
you know,
have always been warriors.
They've always seen this in strategic terms.
I'm not sure people,
conservatives and naturally more self effacing conservatives tend to be a little
bit cool,
a little bit more chill about things they kind of don't really want.
Do you really big draw it though?
How do you explain [inaudible]?
I think they get very angry about things.
Explain Ted Cruz,
what am I saying?
Old Conservatives,
but he explained,
what's her name,
the Pailin chick.
Sarah Palin.
How to explain that.
These are the,
these are the outline is that Mike Huckabee,
even most conservatives find these people a bit much.
How could be,
I think that guy's in isn't the end.
Who knows how much fatter now he was holding,
he ran last time.
Well,
I mean,
you know,
for like the lazy got that push TV gigs.
So fat he got so far I cannot vote for anyone that phenomena rock and rolling.
I want my Rubio just because he's hot.
You know,
if we call out Trump that I won't regret it.
I don't think that,
I think people are silly.
So whether or not it's a conservative thing or a liberal thing,
I think there's a vast majority of people that aren't not very good at looking
at themselves and they're not very good at looking at the momentum of their
actions.
They just think that they're right because this is what they've,
they've been saying for so long.
And I think that's one of the most horrific things about these conversations
with these women.
Get in with you about cause like when,
when they're talking about what they think are social constructs,
like gender identities and the way people be.
And when you shatter that with the facts,
they're looking for some other weapons and there's nothing there and you see it
in their eyes,
you know?
Right.
Cause it's not really a debate about the idea itself.
It's just not what,
it's not.
What it's about is gender warfare.
That's why people like Christina Hoff summers called them gender warriors
because these aren't people who want any kind of social justice as they say.
These are people who just hate men.
Well they hate men.
They want to hurt man.
They don't want equality for women.
They want to,
they want superiority for women.
Whether it's architected into the education system or you know,
affirmative action or whatever it is.
They don't want to quality.
They want superiority.
And fundamentally,
a lot of this,
you know,
these,
these crazy extremist,
you know,
uh,
progressive third wave feminists,
today's version of feminism.
It basically boils down to [inaudible] and it takes a gay guy because it's so
dangerous for men to even broached this subject anymore.
And any man with a mainstream job puts that at risk by even talking on the
subject no matter what his opinion is.
Um,
it takes a gay guy to go on,
you know,
Sky News in the UK and say,
I'm sorry,
the facts are not on your side and what you're doing is damaging to women.
Um,
it's to me really an indictment on a,
on debate in our public square that it is so dangerous for a man to even express
an opinion on this subject that it takes a fag to go and stick up for,
for heterosexuals.
If other men could say this,
they would be,
but they can't because they would risk their careers.
Feminists always talking about silencing.
Yeah.
People,
I see science to men that that is true.
There's a lot of doxing and going after people and a lot of,
a lot of anger when it comes to all this stuff.
But I think what you have in many cases when you see this kind of like
disjointed,
illogical sort of way of thinking,
I think you have people that are assholes that find a cause that gives him the
green light to be an asshole.
Well,
I read about this,
you know,
I agree with you.
I think,
no disrespect to any particular church,
but I think it's reasonable to say 50 years ago if you were a bully,
if you are a sociopath,
do you want you to take out in other people?
You want it to Rick harm on the world that you thought would hurt you?
Reasonably good way of doing that would be to join the clergy and many and many
people did.
And I think most of us who are religious,
who have religious families know stories like that.
These days you're better off getting a job at Gorka.
Um,
you know,
if you want to bully somebody,
if you really want to hurt them,
if you have some sort of internal chaos or damage and you want to impose order
on the world outside because you feel so confused and broken and messy,
uh,
the best way to do it today,
it's become a social justice warrior.
Because not only do you get the same kind of status in society the clergy would
have done 50 years ago,
but you also get media platforms.
You get money,
you get approval,
you got applause.
And if you layer on these new tactics of,
you know,
fake abuse and fake harassment,
and you know,
these terrible man,
you know,
these terrible men coming for me on the Internet and stuff,
you can make what?
A lot of money too.
[inaudible]
okay.